Pete is with us in Cincinnati hey Pete
how are you I'm better than I deserve
brother it's a honor to talk to you you
too sir what's up I have one big
question my wife and I have been doing
your plan for about four years now it's
been a huge blessing we got out of about
$100,000 of debt and we've saved up
three to six months which is good
because I'm changing careers here in
about two months but my parents are in a
very bad financial situation they're
both retired they bring in good money
but they also spend a ton of money and
they've got about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars or more worth of debt
and I have talked to them they're
planning on moving in with us
because every month they can't afford to
pay all of their bills and I want to
make sure we want to help them out but I
want to make sure they don't end up
living with us for forever we have a new
baby on the way and value our privacy
and so what do they want to make sure
they bring in I would say they probably
bring in about 125 or 130 a year with
their various retirements and how old
are they 70 and 65 okay and so they make
plenty of money they have just
misbehaved they they've lived well
beyond their means or the spin like
they're in Congress yes they're
misbehaved you know so how is moving in
with you helping your roll up your
sleeves and POW feet dadgum death well
right now they can't afford living in
their house well how much is her house
wind
I believe they're paying twenty five
hundred a month somewhere around there
so sell it and go rent something go rent
something for half of that and get your
butt out of debt you make 125 thousand a
year
the problem is I sat down and and went
through their budget with them basically
set up a budget for them a couple maybe
a month ago and even with selling their
house and taking that payment out they
don't have money because of all of the
payments that they're making on their
various debts and so I set up a plan
with them what are they what are their
own cars they are I think about fifteen
on a car which they're telling me they
will not sell I do not let these people
move in with you they are not that they
are misbehaving and they are not dealing
with the core problem you want this more
than they want it well that's very true
my wife keeps saying that very thing
this is not good they need to go rent
something cheap and get with a financial
coach and get into Financial Peace
University and sell everything in sight
and rent $1000 place and or an $800
place and drive a thousand dollar car
and they make a hundred and twenty five
to one hundred and forty or whatever it
is you thought they made and they pay
off a hundred thousand they can pay off
a hundred thousand but they spend money
like they're in Congress housing is not
their problem the person in the mirror
is their problem
well you're right I guess my question is
if they if they do end up moving in with
us
where dude I just have already moved I
know I know you did
they've already moved in some of their
stuff in an attempt to sell their house
what what would be your recommendation
for trying to put some type of plan in
place to where they're not here forever
I would put heavy requirements on them
that they sell the car and that they
beyond the budget they go through
Financial Peace University and they go
see a financial coach and that all
happens in the first 30 days or you need
to look for a new place
and guess what they're gonna do they're
gonna move out because they're not ready
to deal with you because they're not
ready to deal with their stuff and
you're not gonna be strong enough to do
that that's what your wife's worried
about you're gonna have to put some down
some hard stuff that's good for them man
I'm not going to be mean to them
but what's good for them and I'm not
gonna participate in their crazy
[Music]